I look like Where's Waldo going to P
Diddy's white party or I look like
Where's Waldo that just got scared
non-stretch my boo take it or leave it
but if you leave it just know I'm going
to take it that this hat make me look
like I'm trying too hard it is the
holiday season so I have inferred
because I do not know what day or time
it is anymore and I've just taken some
observations and stores seem to be
selling Christmas holiday time means
presents that you have to give other
people that have bought you a present
that you did not expect to buy you a
present and now you just need to counter
feed their narcissism by giving them a
present if we don't communicate at least
every two months please don't find me a
present unless you're my mother because
yes sometimes we don't communicate that
long and that's my fault
I get it here's a tangential thought but
bear with me it's going to make sense I
hate confrontation actually hate it
gives me hives I'm probably getting
hives just thinking about it or
sometimes it is beneficial to tell
someone that they're doing something
that's negative to the people and things
around them a great way to do that is by
giving them a gift a gift that sends a
message a message that you didn't have
deliver with your mouth so today I
present to you the best progressive gift
guys here are some very inexpensive
gifts that you can give out this holiday
season to let that special someone know
just why they're so special give you the
gift of a doormat because it's how they
make you feel how about a snow shovel
for those who need to dig out their car
in the snow and for those that are just
so shallow why not try some gourmet Jam
or peanut butter for those that are
really good at smothering cute socks
you're always the head give them the
gift of cute feet while they walk all
over everyone around them maybe a
dreamcatcher so you can make it more
efficient for them to catch your dreams
and crush them how about some hair gel
because they're so jealous twenty one
dollar bills because you know they hate
change
how about a signed Jodie Sweetin aka
Stephanie tanner headshot because it's
amazing how rude they are try a tape
measure so they can always measure how
distance they're being maybe a gift
certificate for a manicure or some cute
gloves so their hands can stay warm and
look cute while they hold onto those
grudges garbage cans are always great
for those that are really wasteful a
pregnancy test is really great for that
special guy in your life so he can
really see how negative he's being there
are so many cute placemats out there you
can give that special someone an extra
special spot to place blame a yoga mat
is a classic gift no matter where they
go it can always stay self set
for the animal lovers out there why not
a pooper-scooper
is they're really good at treating
people like and a bonus why not the
bowdabra Grace's guide the art of
pretending to be a grown-up you're
probably super passive-aggressive in an
unhealthy way it might need some
guidance from someone just like you
there you go there's my
passive-aggressive gift guide for the
holiday season hopefully it's helpful
and hopefully it doesn't destroy any of
the relationships you have with people
that are seemingly not the greatest
people and it was this helpful or was
just hurtful presents I don't know oh
hello you look
like you if you liked this video don't
give it a thumbs up I want to see if I
say this and it happens because I've
been hearing a lot about the secret
lately thoughts of things if this video
we can get 15,000 likes on it let's find
out can you do it
also don't forget to subscribe for more
just like this
and I'm thinking about doing a live
stream book chat now the books been out
for a little bit
Grace's guide book calm if you don't
already have it it makes great gifts I
think about doing a live stream so let
me know if you guys would be in just
updating that talking about the book
maybe reading some stuff who knows maybe
some guests if you would like something
like that we'll try and figure out a
date for it and we'll hang out with each
other and drink and pumpkin spice
cinnamon Christmas tree gingerbread
lattes I don't have it what bye